ya hemos mencionado en vídeos anteriores
que si algo se mueve en una trayectoria
circular con una rapidez constante su
velocidad va a cambiar constantemente a
qué se debe esto a que la velocidad es
un vector y un vector no solo tiene
magnitud que es su rapidez sino que
también tiene una dirección así que
aunque este punto tenga la misma rapidez
que este otro punto la velocidad tendrá
otra dirección aquí dibujamos el vector
con la misma longitud para representar
que la magnitud es la misma aquí escribo
la rapidez como v sin la flecha encima y
ésta no cambia pero la dirección apunta
a otro lado para que la dirección cambie
es necesario que esta pelota que se
mueve en una trayectoria circular se
esté acelerando esta es la única forma
de poder cambiar la velocidad que exista
una aceleración al principio esto parece
poco intuitivo porque la magnitud no
está cambiando solamente cambia la
dirección pero cualquier cambio en la
velocidad siempre implica una
aceleración en vídeos anteriores vimos
que estás
siempre va a ir hacia adentro si tenemos
un movimiento circular uniforme a esta
aceleración hacia adentro le llamamos
aceleración centrípeta si escribo
simplemente esta a c significa que es la
magnitud de la aceleración cuando
hablamos de la magnitud y la dirección
le agregamos una flecha encima de igual
forma en vídeos anteriores hemos
relacionado la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta con la velocidad
lineal y el radio la fórmula que
encontramos es la aceleración centrípeta
es igual a la magnitud de la velocidad o
la rapidez lineal al cuadrado dividida
entre el radio lo que vamos a hacer en
este vídeo será relacionar la
aceleración centrípeta con la velocidad
angular nuestra variable omega omega es
la magnitud de la velocidad angular aquí
la clave es relacionar la rapidez lineal
con la rapidez angular en vídeos
anteriores cuando vimos el concepto de
la velocidad angular o mejor dicho su
magnitud que es la rapidez angular vimos
que la velocidad lineal
igual al radio de la trayectoria
circular uniforme multiplicada por la
magnitud de la velocidad angular en
general no me gusta memorizar las
fórmulas prefiero deducir las recuerden
que la magnitud de la velocidad angular
se mide en radiales por segundo y a los
radiales típicamente los vemos como un
ángulo pero si pensamos en los radiales
como la longitud de arco podemos pensar
en un radial como cuántas longitudes del
radio se recorren por segundo por lo que
si se multiplica esto por la longitud
del radio entonces tendremos una idea de
la distancia que se recorre por segundo
espero que esto tenga sentido para
ustedes demostramos esta fórmula en
vídeos anteriores y a partir de esta
fórmula es fácil sustituirla en la
fórmula original para encontrar una
expresión de la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta en términos del
radio y la magnitud de la velocidad
angular los invito a que pause en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar esta fórmula
por su cuenta
resolvamos estos juntos si comenzamos
con esto tenemos
que la magnitud de la aceleración
centrípeta va a ser igual a r por omega
sustituimos la v por lo que tenemos aquí
y la elevamos al cuadrado vamos a
escribirlo la rapidez lineal es igual a
r por la rapidez angular así que donde
encontremos la v vamos a sustituirla por
r por omega
aquí tenemos r por omega al cuadrado
entre r y ahora vamos a simplificar lo
usamos una de las propiedades de los
exponentes r por omega al cuadrado es
igual a r al cuadrado por omega al
cuadrado todo esto entre r r al cuadrado
entre r va a ser igual a r esta es la
fórmula para la aceleración centrípeta
en términos de la velocidad angular es
igual a r por la magnitud de la
velocidad angular al cuadrado en
próximos vídeos usaremos esta fórmula
para resolver algunos ejemplos con esto
terminamos